[Music]
good evening I'm Shannon Bremen for
breath their president Trump's comment
that he does not believe North Korean
Kim jong-un was aware of the
mistreatment that led to the death of an
American college student is getting
major pushback tonight from the boy's
parents Fred and Cindy warmbier say Kim
and his evil regime are responsible and
that excuses and lavish praise cannot
change that late today the president
tried to explain himself senior
political correspondent Mike Emanuel is
at the White House tonight as the
president gets back to business after
disappointing summit in Vietnam good
evening mike shanin good evening to you
president Trump is on defense following
the controversy over the death of
american student otto warmbier the
president is blaming the North Koreans
but not calling out their leader on
Twitter late today President Trump tried
to clarify of course I hold North Korea
responsible the president concluded I
love Otto
and think of him often in Vietnam the
president did not blame Kim jong-un
I really believe something very bad
happened to him and I don't think that
the top leadership know about it
the parents of otto warmbier expressed
outrage and heartbreak disagreeing with
the president saying Kim and his evil
regime are responsible for the death of
our son Otto Kim and his evil regime are
responsible for unimaginable cruelty and
inhumanity no excuses or lavish praise
can change that the president has taken
heat from both sides Kim jong-un knows
everything that happens in this country
certainly with respect to an American
who's been held prisoner there we should
be naive about this regime
the way they mistreat their own people
and certainly the way they mistreated
out of warm beer while in Vietnam
president Trump's former fixer Michael
Cohen spent three days testifying on
Capitol Hill mr. Trump won after Cohen
on Twitter
Michael Cohen's book manuscript shows
that he committed perjury on a scale not
seen before he must have forgotten about
his book when he testified Cohen
attorney Lanny Davis said the president
was lying adding some time in early 2018
mr. Cohen was offered a substantial
advance for a proposal regarding a book
on understanding Donald Trump mr. Cohen
ultimately elected not to proceed but
this is just the beginning Kohn's due
back on Capitol Hill March 6th executive
Felix aider who worked on a proposed
deal to build a Trump Tower in Moscow is
expected of here March 14th and
Democrats are signaling they intend to
call even Trump family members such as
daughter Ivanka and son-in-law Jared
Kushner the Democrats intention is for
this investigation to go through 2020
into the next election there's no
question about it and if they don't find
evidence occlusion which they haven't or
obstruction which they haven't then
they'll look for something else the
president was also greeted by a New York
Times piece saying mr. Trump personally
overruled his then White House chief of
staff legal counsel and intelligence
officials demanding a top secret
clearance for senior advisor Kushner it
reportedly alarmed senior officials and
then chief of staff John Kelly wrote
what's described as a contemporaneous
internal memo about the matter the
president denied getting involved in the
security clearance issue back in
November 2016 on Twitter writing I am
NOT trying to get top-level security
clearance for my children this was a
typically false news story today
oversight chairman Elijah Cummings
demanded answers from the White House's
top lawyer I am now writing a final time
to request your voluntary cooperation
with this investigation White House
advisers say they do not talk about
security clearances but Kellyanne Conway
says the president has the absolute
right to do what was described Shanon my
giving you live at the White House thank
you Mike